on this week's show how to choose the
right mentor in the news why Bolton has
massive potential for buy-to-let
investors and we're gonna be answering
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I am Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to this week's property investors
podcast we have got a mega show lined up
we have we've got a mega shore lined up
there's some good stuff coming up today
before we get started tell us about your
week
yeah week's been busy again it's always
busy man we're always busy what have you
been up to
he says your horse says he's like why do
always put me on the spot and just say
how I was like I went and I did my week
has been well the last thing that I did
was I went to CBeebies land with the
kids
ha ha ha who enjoyed it more you other
kids do you know what it is actually
pretty awesome is it yeah did they have
like our own on like a hotel on site and
exam yeah like a proper room for 2 days
we just stayed one night ok but they're
hurt what I liked about it was they kept
going
they kept ad putting stuff on that you
weren't expecting okay we'll just like a
theme but loads of shows on and the
character doesn't know the only thing
the only blemish on it was the food in
the hotel reminds me of a 2 for 10 pub
okay right but the meal cost like 120
quid for the forest so it was like the
service wasn't it really felt like you
know it had a wacky where has to know is
a kids restaurant via if you're gonna
have that quality don't charge 120 quid
yeah it's like a like a em yeah X school
dinner type foods they it was it was a
bit it was like like I said like you
know one of those pubs where it's like
two for ten yeah it reminded me of that
kind of quality yeah that kind of you
know so but other than that they went
above and beyond that everything else
was brilliant yeah
enjoyed it the hotel was amazing the
girls liked it the girls loved left
absolutely loved it yeah that age is
well and they worse that's real it's
really good for them yeah yeah so had a
very good weekend so of you been up to
em okay so we just come back from a
training event in London that was pretty
cool and and hold on can I just can I
kind of set the scene for this yeah
about a month ago we talked about
ordering but we talked about ordering
new cars you have now ordered your car I
have what were you gone for abnormal I
have gone for a grey agate a grey
Porsche a PMA no a Getty
aga-aahh so disappointed Oh gasps Oh
gasps degree Porsche Cayman GTS with
black wheels nice it is stunning
beautiful the tires are black you made
or none of the wheel was a black alloy
is a wheel I was of like satin black
it's a beautiful car maybe NIC can put a
picture of you sure you want game but
it's ordered I'm expecting delivery in
six weeks and I cannot wait because I've
always my I'm not a massive car fan you
are no I'm not like do you know
something like super super cars I'm not
that into it but since I remember I've
always one of the Porsche always wonder
Porsche Porsche Porsche wherever but
what was one one and now finally in a
position where we can get one you could
always have my Porsche we'll have a
little Drive little little little to the
roof down is it still not parked at the
side of the road because it broke down
no I fixed it are you fixed it right
okay it's working again the roof wasn't
wasn't working but it is now the roofs
not the reason it was at the side of the
road it's broke then cuz the engine died
and in there no just the coil if it was
the engine running when you left it
yeah were you driving it when you left
it yeah so why do you leave it aside the
road it wasn't running right it felt
really wrong and it smelt weird so I
pulled over and left it okay I then
drove it I then went and picked it up
next same drivers and mechanics and you
replace the call it's fine
okay that's cool oh no I don't want you
I'd rather just go over the one I've
ordered it's much nicer so what's
happening in today's show okay so first
of all how to choose the right mentor
yeah
do you know we can ask this question a
lot and somebody actually commented on I
think it was YouTube asking this
question so we thought we'd discuss it
today so yeah how do we well it's a very
good question I think the first thing
that you need to do if you is you want
you need to decide what it is that you
want to achieve you kind of comes back
to goals doesn't it yeah so what is it
what is it you want to be like what is
it you want to achieve what is it you
want to do and I would personally say
for me it's crazy to have multiple
mentors in different areas yeah so you
might have a few different areas of your
life that you want to work on and you
might choose a different mentor for each
area because that you're never gonna
find the perfect person that you want to
be like in every way no maybe people
that a lot of like a very good at see
might for example let's say you want to
become good at sales you might have a
sales mentor yeah you might have a
property mentor you might have a health
mentor and you've got people that you
look up to in the in the fields where
you want to improve so I would say first
thing is decide what you how you want to
be what you want to be like and don't
don't limit yourself here because you
can be I really believe you can be
whatever you want to be mm-hmm
completely entirely believe you as well
I don't think you should put any I think
a lot of the time we think you know
we've got limiting beliefs and we put
ourselves in a little belief box like
this yeah where is really the potential
is astronomical obviously a few weeks
back I've done warrior training yeah and
that really enforces that how strong you
actually are and how much you can do in
life and how much you can do with
yourself personally mentally and
physically and I completely believe that
they anybody can do whatever they want
and you just need to get the right
guidance and right support one of it one
of the biggest things that holds back is
our beliefs yeah
and you've got beliefs about yourself a
lot of them come from when you were a
child so you might have it you might
have a belief that you know oh I'm no
good at art yeah oh I'm no good at
dancing or I'm no good with numbers or
whatever it is and you've got these
beliefs and the thing is if you believe
it it will be it will be true so if you
believe I'm no good at numbers
you won't work with the numbers you'll
ignore it and use the things you focus
on broaden their so if you're focusing
on how you can't do something then
that's gonna get bigger and bigger and
bigger and you're always gonna keep
telling yourself you can't do it yeah
you need to stop telling yourself you
can do it yeah you choose to do it and
you want to do it and if you step tell
yourself that then then you'll do it
like I really want to lay on like a
musical instrument I've never been I've
never thought I'd been very musical but
you could bring that warrior I met a
musician who's quite a well he's quite a
well-known musician in Germany and he he
was sure me like how to how to like
learn the keyboard and things and he
says it's very easy mmm so like we're
gonna have that like some facetime live
videos a guy called Dawson Church
he's like a scientist he experimentation
and Ament all sorts of stuff he talks
about Martin mind over matter in these
ayahs and he always believed that he was
rubbish at art okay and he took it back
to when he was six years old
he was quite shy kid he drew a piece of
art at school and they were they were
are brilliant that's great well done you
know great job yeah he then took it home
showed his mom and she laughed at him
and she was like ha ha ha jumped around
good everyone look out rubbish she's
basically not she was trying to be mean
but she the proportions all that sort of
stuff and it like crushed him yeah he
didn't draw again he didn't do any arts
and since and he just always believed
I'm crap yeah at art and then when he
was 45 he he was challenging but beliefs
about himself that were limiting beliefs
and this was one of them is the iron
crapper eyes why do I think that and he
went back and he remembered he was like
okay I've chosen to believe that I'm
crap at art because of this right that's
it I'm not gonna believe that anymore
like going on classes art classes and he
ended up he went to like he got like a
one-man show at this art gallery and
they asked me to drill 36 pieces of art
he was doing watercolor and he was
awesome awesome out of here and he
always believed always strongly believed
that he wasn't
sticking his crapper up and then he gave
it up took my rice and we started doing
scientific research like that but I just
thought wow amazing it it is amazing you
know you think that your your crap at
something when you think you're not very
good at it and it you believe in you
hadn't it stops you from then and then
going out there and doing it and the
truth is and I really believe I really
believe this the truth is is that as
humans we've got the capability to do
anything it's all about practice yeah
it's all about working at it and putting
the effort in and they've got a rule
called the 10,000 hour rule and that
they say that anyone if they put 10,000
hours of practice into it purposeful
practice trying to improve can become
world class world class not just good
but work I said anything they want
interesting and it's kind of it's
scientifically proven and then they take
a case of a lot of the people that they
used to say that isn't true they'll wear
out the Wonder kids though what about
people like Mozart Mozart was a one
wonder me no wonder musician at the age
of five yeah but he used to practice for
like seven hours a day from the answers
like to a lot of people don't see that
practice how many times have you been to
like I get this a lot and people think
that you've suddenly got overnight
success but they don't see all this
stuff that's been going on for ten years
they only see suddenly wow you're making
all this money you do know you're doing
all the great things but that's
overnight because it appears overnight
but there's there's been years and years
and years and years of practice practice
practice practice practice
hard graft practice practice practice
practice practice Serena and Venus
Williams yeah everyone's la freakin H
just got god-given get know their dad
said when they before they were born my
children are gonna become professional
tennis players
he built a tennis the table dad not
table tennis helps he built a tennis
court in his back guard and he had the
map practicing hours a day from the age
of like three so it's all about practice
it's all about so you can do whatever
you want to do and anything any other
belief that you've got just isn't the
case so I would say is first of all get
that small thinking hat off yeah they
realize that you can do whatever it is
you want to do
what any literally anything that's
physically possible yeah you can do it's
true so from our listeners and our
viewers what would they do what steps
would be okay so what I would choose a
mentor ago that can be that doesn't have
my notes well not me so this is the
first property I know what you won't
why don't we want to do yeah yeah then
you want to find the people that you
relate to yeah the have done what you
want to do so a lot of mentors are
people that are literally they they get
a deal a property deal or they do this
and then suddenly they're there they're
a mentor yeah right so fine you know do
do your honor I don't want to bang on
about due diligence but do have a look
at the people and find that find the
people that are actually doing the do
find the people that are doing what you
want to do not just telling about it
yeah not this is it 10 years ago and now
they're this fine people that are
actually you know I would aspire I think
your mentor should always be someone
that you aspire to be like
and you might outgrow you know you I've
had mentors that I feel like I've
outgrown I've been in a situation of
like wow I want to be like that and then
I kind of get there and then I'm on to
the next and I want to be like this now
and that's funny true mental or if
they're true mentor they'll encourage
that they're not gonna be this quit
they're not going to be annoyed or
offended by that they'll discover their
lil encouraged yeah of course and I
think that our listeners exactly what
you said find out what you want to do if
you want to do property find out who in
property you want to be like if you want
to do business find out who in business
want to be like but even better find
someone who who is getting other people
up to their their level yes
so if you find someone s doing what
doing what you want to do but be you can
see but we call it you know proven
results you can see the other people but
they have been mentor to are getting the
results that you want as well and like I
say it might be something that you do
for a couple of years and then you move
on to another mentor but so would you
say a mentor has to be 20 years
experienced has to be in the industry
for years and years and years no do you
know what I believe a mentor should be
what
is somebody that is been doing it and as
ahead of you hmm
and then then the mentor should be
pulling you along and helping you get to
where their app yeah and then if you
bypass them so be it but I think it's
just something that's being doing it
that's doing it now currently Inc in
today's market whether that's business
property health and fitness anything
that are doing it and and you you can
relate to them and copy them and if you
work them is what do you think when you
see like health coaches and stuff that
are overweight you've got to look at
where they're at in the journey law if
they are overweight so this just see
they are they are em I don't know like
20 stone but last year they were 30
stolen at the end the journey they were
on a journey Huntley it was net but then
maybe then that maybe they could target
people were 30 so yes so uh what I mean
okay fine I
let's take me I'm I'm on a bit of a
fitness thing I'm trying to lose weight
and what sort stop in a minute right I
wouldn't want a mentor that's bigger
than me because I'm like if you're that
good at it why are you bigger than me
nothing is right let's say you'd lost a
stone yeah you're not ready to be a
fitness mentor I am no not at all
so that's what I'm so if you are I think
if you're if you're a mentor you should
be good at it it should be good at it
yeah so someone that I'm teaching health
it should be slim someone who's teaching
propositions are proper to do some of
this teaching business should have had a
business you see so many business
coaches and stuff they get trying to be
a business coach I never had their own
business
yeah no no how can you how can you be if
you've not done this bring it to
property for a minute
Facebook is full of mentors of people
that are offering mentorships but
they've they've got no deals or they've
got very few deals so how then have
there's lots of people are offering to
do it yeah how do you find that you have
to good you have to go off results golf
result you have to go off results
through first of all have they doing it
themselves
yeah secondly have they helped other
people to do it yeah and the other thing
that I do is I find people that I relate
to so I often start with books yeah so
if I read someone's book and I
really like it I really connect with
them Bob okay do they have a live
program I can go to it yeah okay they do
let's go to that see what happens guys
see it and see where it see where you go
from try and meet them see what happens
see if you connect with them you should
like your mentor as well and you should
trust them you should trust that they're
gonna do a good job for you
here's next thing that do you think you
need a personal mentor who's kind of
like what what exactly do you mean by
mental see I don't have anybody as a
mentor who sits down once a week and
goes right where you are
no I don't have anyone that's like that
I mean I've got friends that are
successful but I mean took him just be
somebody that you aspire to be like or
you aspire to have the similar results
to them that you follow so like let's
take Samuel he's got obviously people
that want an Academy there so he's their
mentor but he's also got like his free
YouTube stuff they could class all the
people that watch out could also class
Samuel as their mentor because they're
still learning of him and you men you
have mentees you probably doesn't know
you do but you do I do because people
watch what I do people watch what you do
and they look up to be like us so you
don't it doesn't matter where you're at
in your journey there's people doing
better than you there's people not not
doing as well as you so the people that
do not as well as you might look up to
me for instance and let them look up to
you and say I want to be like Russell
Leeds he seems to be doing really well
they look up to me I want to be like
Alistair he's doing very well so that we
are indirectly mentoring them because
they see what we do they read our books
they watch what would they watch this so
we are mentoring people now hmm so would
you say then so what you want to do is
you want to find people that you look up
to yeah find people that you want to be
like that are helping other people and
then just follow them I I would I would
that be a start and then if you like
them and if they offer paid mentorship
in then go with it mm-hm don't be a
stump be scared to invest money in a
good mentor because you're not investing
in the mint are you messing yourself
yeah but like obviously you invest in
our mentorship program or whatever don't
be scared to because if you know you're
gonna get the results Matt it's an
investment it's no different to invest
in
property investing are a watchable
animate the matter you're investing in
yourself now I'm investing you know
didn't notice woman right let me take
time on Facebook a few weeks ago I saw
some some day make something the most
idiotic comment I've ever seen can I
guess what it is gone because I saw one
I thought was stupid I think it was
maybe the same one was it the one that
said and you can't pay a mentor did you
see that one oh no I didn't see that one
they say a mentor should be free so who
wants to mentor me for free okay see
he's obviously broke he's obviously
broke and he wants somebody to do it
give him for free and everyone was going
on like why would you why would they do
for free why would you but having said
that I think you just you just say it
yourself you can actually get mentors
with a very very cheap you can audible
for example I use audible yeah $7.99 a
month yep
YouTube yep there's lot so that's that's
his free mentoring but that I'm not he's
not suggesting that he suggests he wants
somebody to sit down with a mentor and
for free that's what he suggests the
yeah so that the comment I saw was
somebody or on the Facebook group said
why would anybody spend ten thousand
pound on mentoring on a training program
and it to be honest that's a that's a
broke comment that's a comment from a
pure mindset is because why wouldn't you
if you know you're gonna get results why
wouldn't you and I'm not here we're not
plug in what we do well no that's not
what it's about but we're plug in
education and that can be in any form
right but if you pay the right if you
paying money to an education program
force your return on investment gonna be
how much if you're going to put X into
this what you getting out of it now I
invested I've invested a lot of money
like I reckon I've not even calculated
but it's gotta be plus twenty five
thousand pound in the last two years
easy or I can I've done double that as a
stir up all that look at return on
investment so now I've got a business
which is doing like thirty thousand
pound a month easily without straight
which I have systemized because of what
I learned on that mentorship program
I've got a portfolio of properties it's
making men money every month
alone on that mentorship program I'm now
heavily involved with the business
because of my links and my connections
and my meeting people on that mentorship
program so that is the best twenty
thousand pound I've ever spent in my
life so if you go into it think n um who
redid invest money into a mentorship
program then you've got the wrong
mindset to begin with a completely
believe I also think that don't just
focus on like don't just focus on
property no I think you need to focus on
all the areas of your life that you want
to I set the start think about the
perfect you yeah one of the one of the
things that they wanted things Joe
Dispenza teaches and the meditation
stuff is like you know they were
infinite possibilities and you need to
sort of like go forget all the baggage
forget everything start as if you're
starting from scratch as if you're no
one no person just and where what would
you like to be yeah and that's how you
need to forget everything seems really
good way to do it just they see you
later to say today
forget everything's happened in your
past you have just been born yeah you're
a stark bollock naked you have just been
born you're fresh to the world what do
you want to be where do you want to live
where to want to be forget forget where
you live forget all everything that's a
brilliant that's a very good way to do
it and our viewers can do that and our
listeners can do that start again where
do you want to be tomorrow where you
wanna be next year and twelve months
that's next year where you wanna be next
year where you wanna be in five years
forget all your baggage yeah warrior
three or four weeks ago right that
taught you one of the things that you
learned was to drop your baggage and to
get rid of all their this [ __ ] you're
carrying in your life from yourself and
from other people it massively helped me
you need to do that I think you let go
of the baggage for you but for whatever
you do whatever you do let go mmm anger
jealousy guilt there you go yeah move on
so on that note shall we move on it's
now time for this
[Music]
I guess in the news this week I came
across an article Y Bolton has big
potential for buy-to-let property
investors and we often get asked you
know new he wears a place move there so
I just thought I thought we'd share this
so here we go one of the largest towns
in Europe Bolton is it so well I would
never thought that my is also renowned
across the UK is one of the friendliest
places is it thought that okay the
warmth and welcomed visitors received
from local people ake a Bolton Aryans is
a major factor in the town's success as
the place to do business live study and
visits Bolton is building on its rich
industrial and cultural heritage to meet
the needs of a growing population
currently 290 thousand and projected to
exceed three hundred thousand by 2025 so
why is it so good they're planning on
spending how much do you reckon in the
next fifteen years they're planning on
spending renovating Bolton with
commercial developments housing schemes
and also you know doing up the town
central at source stuff it's going to be
a couple of hundred mil in it a bill
yeah where's that money coming from
grows on trees doesn't it well I know
where it's come from
probably but I don't know maybe we'll
probably just go hit the country going
into debt to do it many probably you
know like we usually don't wonder if
that's European money I never understand
hammer how we are in so much debt and
house why all the countries are in so
much debt is who is it who's sitting at
the top of the tree lending this money
to the debt to the IMF International
Monetary Fund let's print my I don't
know they just do quantitive easing
whenever they want more money they just
put some more money yeah I'd love what
I'd like one of them printers also it's
a key player in the Greater Manchester
economy I think this is the key right
Manchester is going up a lot Bolton's
right near any of you and it's gonna
it's gonna be people are commuting is
gonna be the awful didn't know they're
the people that can't quite afford to
live in Manchester but the live in
Bolton and surround and get
they've already created 100 million
development fund to kick-start
development interesting so building a
lot of new houses imagine Bolton would
be fairly good for likes of HMOs and
things are then the mid middle brook
which is their shopping center it's
gonna be the biggest shopping center in
Europe is it apparently so
this doesn't sound think it's going to
happen in Bolton that sounds like I'm
shocked by this because biggest shopping
center in Europe in Bolton it's crazy
isn't it you know if you're listening
from Bolton I'm sure you've got lovely
timing but I just can't see the biggest
shopping center in Europe in Bolton it
doesn't make sense as a building a 31
million health leisure and research
center Wow a business school or law
school
cool so it sounds like Bolton is sounds
like it's place to be is really going
places yeah I mean you wouldn't have you
wouldn't have thought it but it's what
did we know what yeah and maybe we need
to be buying in Bolton maybe maybe we
should all be buying in Bolton may be so
there you go you heard it here first on
the property investors podcast in the
news this week Bolton is the place to
massive potential in Bolton wow now time
for this
[Music]
okay it's now time for your questions
and answers don't forget if you want to
get your questions answered go onto our
Facebook group property investors with
Samuel leads we tends to a Facebook live
in there and you can come on and ask us
questions alternatively if you're
watching us on YouTube stick a question
below yep go first one yeah first one is
from Daniel breast of ik hi could we
work one-bedroom flat for essay in city
centre with sofa bed in the living room
so able to sleep for guests darby sit
darby Nottingham Wakefield or Barnsley
thanks for your advice you do a very
good job thanks for it no problem
Thanks so I'm sort of dissecting that
question you want to know where
apartment work with a 1-bit apartment
would work in a first essay in a city
centre of darby Nottingham Doncaster
Wakefield Barnsley I would say daughter
I would say go for yeah maybe I would
say Derby or Nottingham I'm not don't
have to wait feel Barnsley I don't know
maybe not I don't think is enough there
but yeah I think Darby noting about do
remember what's the biggest use of
essays is this business so as long as
there's there's business is well yeah
that's their short answer is yes one but
yeah one bed would work but I I don't
like one beds because I don't there's
enough profit in them um no I don't so
um I do disagree okay let's go to
disagree you're wrong but it's good I
could agree with you then we'd both be
wrong yeah now I am lately it works for
some what doesn't work for others I
prefer two or three beds because then
you you can get the groups because if
you want for a one bed si pink sofa bed
you've got four people yeah that's fine
so soft base we could sleep for people
but one bed si right now answers answer
this question honestly okay you're going
to Nottingham for honestly I don't see
afternoon all right fine you're going to
Manchester for conference yeah are you
gonna stay in a service combination or a
hotel Hotel every day the week alright
so now you go into the you go into
Manchester for our trip away with Anna
and the kids are you want to see
Hotel ourselves condition service
correlation exactly you get four in
there okay fine
so I L to be friends and to friends yeah
but that would happen over quite being
generate just prove Jack all yet gone
number one right just because I would do
that so no you just said well you said
the number one uses business you can
send them one use families going on a
little vacation
even if I'm traveling on business Amman
I wouldn't see in a service company
neither without people do really well
this is the number one but when we do
the composition no I find that I failed
stain in essays hard work so hard work
because I went to I stayed an essay in
Liverpool and I thought like I'm I run a
say I thought I'm gonna stay in an essay
and see what the experience is like it
was horrible right because the I got the
confirmation from booking.com
and it wasn't I had to go and pick the
keys up from not the property there was
no no it was a car that was their office
but it was only it was like point eighth
of a mile away so they had not no
worries you can walk it and half an hour
around round-trip yeah that's fine but
when you've been on the road twelve
hours
yeah I'm saying it's a joke it's a joke
so I I drove to the venue their office
and they said yeah don't worry just go
out here turn left and it's down there
took me 45 minutes to get from the
office to the to the the the the
residence and then they said oh you've
got to bring the key back in the morning
oh yeah okay bring it back the nice lift
and in the apartment is the wheels bring
the back but my point it was hard work
so they if I'm traveling for business
I'll always stay in a hotel
yeah me too when I went to when I went
to Barcelona last year we stayed it
obviously though the family were going
and we stay today is that way you've got
less bad feedback
yeah it was German I was at sorry so we
stayed in like it and a villa and it was
similar had to pick up the keys from the
office but I didn't find it confined the
office and then when we did was closed
because we got there late and we're like
phone in them and then it was awkward
and a nightmare what can I just put on
so anyway yeah an a/c will work i
personally
more than one bedroom and I know a lot
people that when I say say the same
Russell says one bedroom so I don't know
do it let us know how it's going on hope
it works I say one [ __ ] better budge
the wall my gyms fine you think my
mother's finance fact so darby
nottingham i would say over Doncaster
Wakefield in Barnsley okay next one from
rosemary Davies hey guys is it possible
to get a bridge in lawn without being
able to hold it against the house and no
one in my circle will enable me to do
this through them as far as I'm aware
the answer is no it has to be secured
against against the property or a
property any into that either you're
right so that's what I've always okay
next question from David chambers
hey David chambers hey guys great show
David if a landlord is tired because a
bad tenant is it going to cause you
problems when you're taking over the
property LOA style thanks not
necessarily because it might be because
they're a bad landlord or they're just a
stress head you get some landlords that
just don't stress heads no lil this
problem get grip I find some landlords
just don't like tenants and any any
issue causes a massive issues and the
thing then is do then start thinking
badly of all tenants because no I mean
case in point
my lease option that I've got in
Wolverhampton and the land a lot of
stress ed but he was tired he didn't
wanna do it anymore and he was saying to
me very adamant you'll never get more
than 700 pound a month for this property
never get more than $70 per at 7-under
per month was property and I make I
thank you I I believe you can I take
that risk
and he's that yeah yeah half of these
FAA so we agreed a deal might that
probably gets 1500 an 80-pound
every single month because my mindset is
different
well his mindset was student students
judgment lowing lowing lowing limit my
mines next next David agua agua reaiiy
Guara is rent service accommodation
legal in Scotland yes you heard it here
and on that note that is the last
question of today well guys thank you
ever so much for tuning in don't forget
to check us out next week we're back
Saturday at 7 p.m.
and please subscribe and show us some
love we like to be loved we love love
love oh it's a guys wasn't my tower I'll
be hugging him right now but like so see
you next week
[Applause]